have you heard the Christmas story no no
not the one about the baby in the manger
the one about the dad who splashed
20,000 pounds on gifts for his children
or what about the celebrity who despite
being nearly declared bankrupt
supposedly treated herself to six grams
worth of new Christmas decorations let's
face it these are the Christmas stories
of our age at least we still call it
Christmas if you head over to the US
this year you'll be greeted by a cheery
Happy Holidays because Americans have
worked out a way to include everyone in
The Consumerist binge fest if you've
been watching the pledge this year
you'll know I am all for inclusion I
have love for everybody's religious
festivals and will be among the first to
which people even Mobarak happy Chanukah
happy Diwali and at Christmas happy
Christmas
you don't have to take part in Christmas
and those who do don't have to be
Christian but if we completely drown it
out in this materialist madness then
everyone will be the poor I mean yes why
should we have people splurging money
they don't have on stuff they don't need
or their loved ones don't even want I
agree I mean it's real buy lots lots of
stuff
I loved my present I hope you like facto
bestseller all over the world that made
my day um you know you could go at one
of two ways I mean when you say it's a
commercial splurge fest yes it is but
actually our retailers we've had a
bloodbath on the high street you know
have Macklin's
pound world what was the other one lots
you know we're not happy anymore or us
Thank You Nick here on the money you
know do we want to have our high streets
which rely for 30% of their business on
Christmas spending or do we want to have
ghost towns and just we all sit at our
computers ordering so I'm not proud of
this I don't really but I have spent a
lot of time in the last few days just
training my bank account on Amazon which
isn't helping that's true
because I haven't had time to go make
the shot in workout you have the white
vans driving around I know and your
stores will probably shut in the new I'm
just saying that assuming that the more
we spend then will we help the high
strip I've never bought anything on
Amazon or any other services you Joe is
forcing you the shop son forcing you to
go advertises on forcing you to do it so
parents who spend 20 grand on presents
for their kids
I think it's nuts frankly I mean the
well it may be a fear income but the
glorious thing about Christmas I think
is that there are massive positives
about it you know we all you know we
give presents to people we love we have
a chance to share we talk to perfect
strangers in the street we miss them
Merry Christmas
everyone's a bit more smiley we go to
parties it is a time of and I don't know
about you guys but I think more about
Charities of Christmas than I ever do it
everything is going on at the moment
Carol you know what big news only
generates actually I should put some in
ahead of time but you know I I just
think I just it's a glorious time you
might have should say my living room
from the moon now it's got so many
lights in it because it makes me happy
good great did you know the 500 tons of
old lights estrangement I agree with you
I think Christmas is a wonderful time I
fear some time when families should
might not see each other a lot getting
together they laugh they eat they have
fun the most remarkable statistic and I
saw though was that in Britain but we
sell 750 million sprouts
this is collected by the Office for
National Statistics which makes you
wonder what what they do the rest of
your time but the interesting thing
about them according to the statistics
is it half of them don't get eaten
so that's 375 million Brussels sprouts
don't getting don't get e outrageous
we do we do spend a lot of Christmas
I've got a stat as well this is the
increase from spending at Christmas food
we increase our spending on food by 16
percent alcohol by nearly 40 clothing 43
percent toiletries which was surprising
56 percent this is overall a typical
household spends over 500 pounds extra
in December but my point is attribution
you don't want clothes everything that I
love Christmas
everything that Kyle says I agree with
but most of the things you're saying
that you love about Christmas aren't
actually about spending money they're
about spending time with family members
talking to strange okay I mean lights
okay they cost a bit but it's generally
kind of the festive spirit and my worry
is that there's so much pressure to
spend to demonstrate your investment
increases because you're sure sports
freshers are all getting iPad it's a
good time to explain to your kids a
Christmas isn't about weirdly it isn't
about getting a nice day sighs we're
gonna see a stat on high street spending
but I found this year I've said to all
my children what do you want they said
they've all said nothing I've got
everything I want we've imported the
deflation from Asia and China for so
long we all got so much stuff I mean
what do we actually need what things you
can eat I don't want anything else
because actually cupboard footfall at
shopping centers retail parks in high
street shops actually fell 3.2 percent
which is a big drop that goes with Black
Friday this shopping spree at all as the
middle of that month or wherever it goes
which I think now is the crazy idea I
know why the stores are doing it but it
will become like fixated on drugs they
will have to shift all their stuff and I
think it's a really dangerous way to go
so for that's happening November is even
worse conversation was the flostor said
she have a five-pound limit on presents
in her house so what are you draining
money out your bank account I was in for
we agree entirely what a good thing to
do why give them a tool that was my that
was my parents idea because it got out
of control we're spending all this money
on stuff that we don't really need or
really want none of us can really afford
it and actually it makes you focus more
on the things that really matter like
family or the things that really matter
can I tell you and here's an interesting
statistic even for you on Christmas Day
last year two thousand five hundred and
ninety people filled in their online tax
returns because you know I've come in
character today so which of you are
actually going to church on this
Christmas that you love as a festival do
anything see it as a religious festival
at all okay do you have to Christmas Eve
allowed people turning out the pub
wandering across to the church now there
may be a little bit gonna get so much
now I shall be going to any religious
services a non-religious yes I celibate
is family that's nothing is better than
also and I think a lot of us you know I
concentrate me Amanda Krishna said
things like you know you become aware
that you're much better off than a lot
of your Christmas people in their own do
stuff like things where that most of his
life every time I see a Salvation Army
purse nothing oh these guys are on the
streets they're collecting most of them
are elderly and yet they're out there in
the coats I think we do more stuff a
Christmas than we do at any other time
the same way I mean when I have noticed
wandering around very shopping centers
behind stuff it's just how many people
there are out on the streets begging
it's quite unbelievable this year you
know compared to say five years ago it's
a massive change and you then have that
dilemma do you give or don't you gear i
I think it's I I'm not sure people very
I don't think you have to beg